oh we got to do it again yes I'm Gonna
Make You Keep dance monkey
[Applause]
this is tough I love her this is tough
because the story that comes to mind is
not a good one wait what yeah I'm so
sorry my youngest probably 12 years ago
13 my youngest came in from school
and she goes Dad Dad you've got to hear
this song from Adele I've never heard a
song like it I said really I said what's
his name says To Make You Feel My Love
said you have to be kidding me right no
I didn't say anything so really tell me
about it
people always ask
you know well which is her favorite
version I said I don't know we haven't
spoke since that day
oh my god when she because you
win the race blowing in your face this
is what I grew up on yeah and the whole
world is on UK's
I would offer you a war brace
Make You Feel My love
I love that it's nice and I gotta tell
you
it's like anything that you cover right
so it's like you you're walking around
going make you feel my love I feel
pretty good about my version
you hear Adele singing
all of a sudden you're like okay I get
it that she just everything she touches
just sings but also it's yes absolutely
but I'm also
sign of such a great song so many people
covered this song whether they've
recorded it for a version or just done
it on for a show like that's a great
song and it's like and it depends on
who's singing it like I grew up with
your version and it's like one of those
things that just it hits me like in such
a different way than maybe when somebody
else sings it because of nostalgia
because I'm a fan like whatever but I
think that's what's so magical about
music it has new life like with other
artists amen and then let's talk about
the songwriter again that's Dylan right
yeah and what Dylan is so great about it
what I'll try and do is I'll try to
impress you right I'll try and go oh
that's clever but Dylan just writes from
there to here it's very straightforward
oh my God and it's it's so
it's so simple it's not simple if that
makes any sense well it's brilliant you
have to be super confident comfortable
to keep it that like straight and yeah I
agree
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]